you know like use basically the Drake
back then right so Drake has billions
who's the highest watch music videos
billions right Billy diva right no no no
no not even its that Korean dude I'm
pretty sure sigh oh you know I party say
that guy that's party with that guy Wars
ago before that hit came out god done
themself or guy named start was a thing
I party with him dude Wow
I swear to God on my life I'll show you
on my Instagram it's actually if you go
through my Instagram feed not you won't
be able to do it seven years ago it's a
very beginning my Instagram feed there's
a picture of me and him in there no one
when I knew his manager he was a friend
age dude I knew his manager he was a
friend and he was like this great artist
named psy is coming here from Korea he
is a kpop star this is when Americans
didn't know what kpop was by the well
okay same but he was like we're gonna
take him out to this bar and we went to
this bar and there were some low-key
like famous people there that like ha
like like Topher Grace I was like haha
how how am i with the guy from that
subject it was so many weird celebrities
that were like around this this thing I
didn't know how it happened and then he
asked um one of the bartender's to go
get him a bucket like a clean bucket and
he listed off all these liquors and he
was like in Korea there's this thing
that him and his friends do where you
dip a cup into this bucket and then you
drink from the bucket it's like a it's
like it's almost like a Long Island iced
tea of alcohol it's like it's like a
fruit punch like yeah but it's a
tradition that I guess he does that him
and his friends do or whatever and I did
it and it was [ __ ] fun and he was
cool as [ __ ] a big English huh or did
you know Gangnam stop he didn't say
anything
yeah he pointed a lot he'd go like this
and there and then I knew what that
meant
shyness shoes with my tongue yeah now he
spoke English his English was broken but
I was tiny views does that video have
that also that was kind of old to like I
feel like Drake or Bieber's beating them
now
no dude 3.2 billion now Gangnam stop oh
I know what beats it baby shark doo doo
doo doo doo doo mama shark/doo doo doo
doo de vie shark grandpa shark/doo doo
doo doo de way dude I'm a shark top five
most video just go to do just like I
dream baby
be sharp for [ __ ] my feud yeah - yo -
most food you can do it on the search on
the search engine there right can't you
write that isn't there a sort by I'm
doing here filter go to just Google then
Google at Durham you count
yeah UK baby shark dude 5.8 billion desu
Pacita oh okay so but that but it's not
the Bieber one it's the daddy yankee one
but that's with beaver no not that one
that no that Louise forgot that one bro
that's the original gun on that one now
that's with beer in it bro
gen desmos you know this is that one
yeah first though this isn't people to
get overwritten along either do it was
good when you see my back rip I pull
myself up like a champ like a champ
thirty times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift